This Wendover Productions video was made possible
by Hover.
Get your unique domain and email from Hover
by going to Hover.com/Wendover and using the
code wendover at checkout.
“It’ll be a cold day in hell before I
let twins fly long-haul over-water routes.”
Those were the words of Lynn Helms—administrator
of the Federal Aviation Administration during
the Reagan administration.
At the time, no commercial american airplane
with two engines was allowed to fly anywhere
farther than 60 minutes from a diversion airport.
The belief was that, if one engine failed,
the other could only safely fly the plane
for about an hour, but this rule severely
limited what smaller planes could do.
On North Atlantic routes like New York to
London, twin-engine planes could only fly
in these areas but a direct route looked like
this.
The options were to either fly a twin-engine
plane on an inefficient routing or fly a inefficient
three or four engine plane.
There was no place for long-and-skinny routes
between smaller cities using smaller planes
since airline couldn’t legally fly those
smaller planes.
This one simple rule changed the very way
airplanes were built.
Now, in the 60’s, this 60 minute regulation
only applied to planes with two engines.
Of course aircraft manufacturers could build
quad-engine jets but those had to be huge
for airlines to make their money’s worth
with their high fuel consumption.
The 747’s of the time could carry more than
400 passengers.
They could therefore only fly on super high-demand
routes like New York to London to have any
hope of being full.
In order to start flying more convenient non-stop
routes from smaller markets, planes had to
get smaller while still being legally allowed
to hop the pond.
That’s where trijets came into play.
With three engines, these planes weren’t
subject to the same 60-minute regulation as
twinjets.
They could easily fly any transatlantic route.
That’s why in the 70s or 80s, the long-haul
jets you’d see at airpots were, for the
most part, either 747’s or trijets like
the DC-10.
This 60-minute regulation was inconvenient
for Atlantic Crossings, but in the Pacific
it actually changed how Hawaii developed.
There are zero diversion airports between
California and Hawaii so the route isn’t
even close to covered under the 60-minute
rule.
As a result, airlines could only fly huge
planes between the mainland and Hawaii which
meant that planes could pretty much only fly
to Honolulu.
There was virtually no service between the
other islands and the mainland which meant
the other islands were severely isolated.
That’s part of the reason why the tourism
industry only picked up on the other islands
in recent decades.
Luckily, change was coming.
The 60 minute rule originated from the days
of piston driven propeller aircraft.
With these, it was far more common for engines
to just stop working mid-flight.
That’s why there were contingency engines.
The regulations just didn’t adapt to the
increased reliability of jet engines.
Statistically, for every failure of a jet
engine, there are 117 piston engine failures.
Once the jet age rolled in, engine failure
just wasn’t as much of a concern, so, in
1985, the FAA begrudgingly granted permission
to Trans World Airlines to fly their twin-engined
767 direct between Boston and Paris—a route
taking it up to 120 minutes away from diversion
airports.
This was the first example of a brand new
FAA certification called ETOPS—“Extended-range
Twin-engine Operational Performance Standards,”
or more colloquially, “engines turn or passengers
swim.”
Before an airline can fly a long over-water
route they have to buy a plane with what’s
known as an ETOPS type rating.
Basically that means that the plane was built
with adequate redundancies, communications
systems, and fire suppression systems to fly
safely if one engine fails.
For example, the 767—the first plane to
get an ETOPS certification—has a type rating
of 180 minutes meaning it can fly anywhere
as long as its 180 minutes from a diversion
airport.
But just because a plane has a type rating
doesn’t mean an airline can fly it ETOPS.
They have to have a special maintenance plan,
a special flight crew, special cabin crew,
special dispatchers, special fuel quantities,
and special passenger recovery plans since,
just because there’s a runway doesn’t
mean that a plane can safely divert since
the emergency doesn’t end once the plane
lands.
Cold Bay, Alaska, for example, is a perfect
diversion airport for routes between Asia
and North America.
It only has six commercial flights per week
nowadays but as a former Air Force Base it
has an enormous runway.
The only issue is that the town of Cold Bay
has a population of 108—its tiny—so any
diversions automatically double or triple
the amount of people in the small town.
There certainly aren’t enough hotel rooms
or restaurants to house and feed stranded
passengers so, if airlines plan to use Cold
Bay as a diversion airport, they need to make
a plan for how to house, feed, and recover
passengers within 48 hours of landing.
Last year an American Airlines 787 was flying
from Shanghai to Chicago when its right engine
had an issue halfway across the Pacific Ocean.
The plane quickly took a left turn diverting
to Cold Bay.
Even before landing the plan was implemented
as flight attendants served a second meal
service early.
Just a few hours after safely landing in Cold
Bay, American’s mechanics took off from
Seattle bound for Cold Bay to start fixing
the plane while Alaska Airlines, American’s
partner, sent a 737 from Anchorage to pick
up the stranded passengers.
Meanwhile, flight attendants served the third
set of meals they had stocked while waiting
on the ground and the coast guard opened their
heated hanger to passengers.
Just 10 hours after the emergency landing,
passengers were on their way to Anchorage
where they spent the night before taking an
American 757 to Chicago.
That was a perfect example of how the passenger
recovery plan worked.
The quick response and defined plan helped
the airline get passengers out safely and
quickly.
Now, because of the solid engine reliability,
numerous redundancies, and well-designed passenger
recovery plans, airlines and airplanes can
now receive insane ETOPS certifications.
The 787 Dreamliner, the plane that diverted
to Cold Bay, has a type rating of 330 minutes.
That means it can fly up to 5.5 hours away
from a diversion airport.
Certain routes over long-ocean stretches in
the southern hemisphere were theoretically
possible in the past with four engine planes
but were economically impossible since airlines
could never fill the large planes on the low-demand
city pairs like Melbourne to Santiago.
With the ETOPS 330 certification, LATAM Airlines
can fly their small 787 economically on this
relatively low-demand route across the South
Pacific.
The Airbus a350 is even rated for ETOPS 370—it
can fly 6 hours and 10 minutes away from diversion
airports.
This plane can therefore fly everywhere on
earth except directly over the South Pole.
Because of this simple rule change, three
and four engine planes are largely a relic
of the past.
Boeing and Airbus’ largest jets are both
their only four engine planes in production—the
747 and a380.
Nearly all North Atlantic traffic today is
on twin-engined planes as smaller and smaller
planes get ETOPS certifications.
Air Canada, for example, flies their tiny
120 passenger a319 with ETOPS certification
daily between St Johns Airport and London
Heathrow.
British Airways even sends the even smaller
a318 between New York and London City Airport.
These routes would have been unimaginable
30 years ago but the reliability of the airplanes
of today mean we need not fear flying small
planes over big oceans.
This video was made possible by Hover.
I talked last time about how Hover is a fantastic
way to get a unique domain just like my new
Wendover.Productions domain but I want to
stress this time how professional a custom
email address is.
For $5 for the entire year, I set up an email
ending in @wendover.productions to forward
to my existing business email.
Not only is this email much more memorable,
it also oozes professionalism.
Surely that’s worth the $5 that you’d
otherwise spend on 1/160th of an ETOPS flight
to London, right?
Anyways, you can get a custom domain and email
from Hover for 10% off, while simultaneously
supporting Wendover Productions by going to
hover.com/Wendover and using the code “Wendover”